whoa
I'm sorry Baba new but I like that song
you know I can get some music around
here oh yeah you can get it right there
Oh or you can get it right there
[Music]
hey right so I want to see you have sex
now cool wanna see Paris help enough sex
with a boyfriend
yes I would alright
I don't know if that was her man no
grain is that night vision you can't
really tell
I got see that one more time man I'm
gonna see one more time just hold this
I'll go in there check it out and then
I'll be right back out all right that
was her all right
laid the sail you sure you don't wanna
see any have sex yeah absolutely sure
math will give us to go to the Knicks
game
Thanks all right I do a great doggy
style I know Ron okay I got my stroke
from you thank you everyone I'm done
with the pond what you want to see them
naked pictures Halle Berry from
swordfish of course I do
damn boo jeering telling their the girl
from choices right she got naked
pictures damn
thanks man Danny yes sir um you into go
play what does go play Lizzie
[Applause]
i cost